on Saturday when we'll be with you next from the
Bell Center Canadians playing Florida tonight
here's Raymond passes across to coer and a save
made who comes in after it he gets hit by Ben
sherat near side it comes for Phillips put it in
back of the net and a centering feed and a quick
shot there from Tyler Johnson that shot goes in
back of the net back to the line it comes again
for Phillips and a shot and a save there Johnson
looking for it no Power Play Goals their past
five they've had chances just can't finish and
kinsky the youngster back there number 55 runs
the power play and there's number 98 Conor Bard
who put it in back of the net and the Red Wings
here with a break cop and coner to coner right
in he scares w a shorthanded goal cop to coer a
Jordy and Mick you get a bonus for that you do
you get four points on his goal oh my goodness
gracious what a start what a beautiful pass by
com over to Comer who just basically chips it
over top of moric and he'll do that a lot P dard
will be looking one way and the shot or the pass
goes the other head always up watch him play here
off the kick plate to Kinski takes the shot hit
a body there's Bard in the rebound Ling out they
bang away at it and they score they get that one
back with 51 seconds left in their power play
they tie it up yeah pinball on that one watch
his head one of the shots watch his head never
doubt he knew where he was going he had two guys
on him but the point was open and he goes to
the to the DOT the first and he's the one that
centered it in after his rebound came right back
to him and he and lion kind of collided a little
bit lion couldn't get back into the net nice
to see C come to the aid last night after the
big hit on gosar who left the game upper body
soreness didn't return but gos is bear okay to
go tonight saved there by lion quick shot in on
moraz bman jumped into The Fray and the Hawks
Bard has it up with Pino Bard in on goal takes
the shot and Miss from the short side he's so
deceptive actually you know what number is most
popular most worn in the Red Wings ever no idea
15 really most worn Redwing jerseys okay B Woods
at did wrap around trying to save by lion on a
chance there for Ryan denado a Boston native who
was drafted by [Applause] Boston back into their
own Zone here for Kevin kinsky oh boy nice pass
and a save by lion off an opportunity from Boris
kachuk mired there by ciders to the line and the
shot goes wide in comes Phillips again to get
it go go go lost that and moved out here by Jake
Walman on for Robbie fabry had a goal last night
nice move there fab right in a goal oh he scored
what a play Robbie fabry red hot it's two to1
Detroit he's looking for a piece of his equipment
oh my goodness did he undress him or what oraz
it got a piece of it as I look at the big board
there's a jock strap hanging on it and it belongs
to Kaiser oh my that's a good example of playing
the puck and not the body up the right wing boards
the braket couldn't handle it but came to Center
ice now he's got it then lost it now he's got it
again right in on goal and a save made on the
former Blackhawk backhanded by kinsky around
for one of the two Johnson's Rees Johnson number
52 got it to Center Ice carried back in here by
Ryan denado denado right in and a save made by
lion along with this line was very good against
Seattle most of their points that shot knocked
down loose in front again oh Anderson's on
it here's bard lost it break here fabri in the
clear and moraza got a piece back in front and
that was just out of the reach of barren to
play the game I don't care if you're a young
Phenom or not try to make a a perfect play
and it backfires on you but uh you know it
was actually a pretty good back check right there
by Kaiser that kind of disrupted Robbie fabry just
enough so he couldn't handle a puck cleanly nice
play by Comer in tight took that one beautifully
and then it gets knocked down and Kaiser moved
it to Center Ice that's the kind of confidence
he's been playing with coner to Raymond just
knocked off stride stayed with it though flips
it across to sherat down low it goes to break it
up front of the net makes it ni scar shat on the
rebound his first in 18 games and
it's 3 to one for Chicago they kind
of messed that up and then Ben sherat after
making the faster to break it follows it up
that's the key and at the Collision in
front of the net chat's got an open net
to tuck it up high under the bar and make
it a two goal lead for the home [Applause]
team the brink it will get the helper
and kill a three on five here's
Raymond Raymond with it again in swings It Wide
Pon back they score coner
what a pass from [Applause]
pan oh [Applause] boy and the key here what a
pass across the ice I believe it was Raymond
that made the pass to it was to Veron Y and then
see Comer's got to have his stick right on the
ice right down there and all Pon has to do is
hit it look at that thing trit R wings.com now
I know Mick you were thinking about that weren't
you absolutely I know you were high slot cost to
spare and it got blocked Mata keeps it in slows
down inside the Zone creates some space throws
it across and then radish took it away from pop
and he's away on the left wing side three Hawks
are up radish to the goal to Berard the shot oh
look at that Lon what a stop from Bard golden
night from confer big save Lion on Conor
Bard Baron Comer tipped it gets it around
for David Pon again to Brink it and Raymond the
other two I haven't mentioned yet gos bear with
a shot oh redirected what a save what a stop
ever by Peter morazzi that's the old windmill
save but that changed Direction too he got him he
was in good position to make that save basically
yeah it went off his high forward might have
got off Raymond in front too with a 945 save
percentage those are some darn good numbers
here's sprung with a shot scores fabry again
you go to the net Robbie fabry parries
it another Power Play goal and it's 5 to
one and a two-goal game
[Music] tonight well it looks like with
9006 to play a nice bounce back from a
late night about 1:30 in the morning they
got in from New York City on that 3-2 loss
to the Rangers last night after leading
three to two to one actually only Boston
and the Rangers ahead of Detroit here's
Bard nice play back hiny rebound just
wide dart on it saved by lions not very many
conversely ryers played a boatload up about
481 Coston coming in and a good save there
by morazzi who got jostled another shot goes
wide nice night and another
win for Alex [Music] lion